Human society is extremely complex and fragile,
built upon various pillars.
One of them is the honeybee.
One out of three meals eaten by humans is made possible by honey bees.
They are so important that if all the honeybees were to die out,
thousands of plants would follow,
which could lead to millions of people starving in the following years.
On top of that,
honeybees have a huge economic impact.
The dollar value of plants pollinated by them each year is around 265 billion.
The food we take for granted with just stop existing without them all,
there would be a massive decrease in productivity food including apples,
onions,
pumpkin's,
and also plants use for feeding livestock and thus extremely important for our
MILCON meat.
Einstein is often quoted as having said,
if honeybees die out,
humans will follow.
A few years later,
actually he probably didn't say that,
but there might be some truth in the statement.
It's unsettling,
but honeybees have started to disappear.
Millions of hives have died in the last few years.
Beekeepers all over the world have seen an annual loss of 30 to 90% of their
colonics.
In the u s alone.
Bees are steadily declining from 5 million hives in 1988 to 2.5 million today
since 2006 a phenomenon called colony collapse disorder has affected honeybees
in many countries and we're not entirely sure what's causing it.
All we know is that it's pretty serious.
Over the last few decades,
bees have seen an invasion of very dangerous foes,
parasites straight out of a horror movie like a carrot pissed woody microscopic
mites that in fact the trickier that's the breathing tubes of bees here they lay
their eggs,
eggs,
and feed from the fluids of their victims,
weakening them considerably and spending their whole life inside the bees or
Varroa destructor a fitting name because they can only reproduce in honeybee
hives and are one of the bees greatest enemies.
The female might ant as a honeybee brute south and lays eggs on the beloved
before it's about to pupate and before the hive bees covered the cell with a wax
capping the eggs hatch and the young mites in their mother feed on the
developing be in the safety of the capsule.
The B is not normally killed at this stage,
just weakened so it still has enough strength to chew it's way through the wax
capping and release itself from the south.
As it does,
it releases the mother might and her new offspring from the south and these are
free to spread across the hive.
Starting the process over again in a cycle of about 10 days.
Their numbers grow exponentially and after a few months this can lead to the
collapse of the entire beehive.
Once outside of the cell,
adult Mites also sunk the bodily fluids of bees and we can them considerably to
make things worse.
They also transmit viruses that harm the bees even more and can lead to birth
defects like useless wings,
but are other threats to such as viruses and fungus.
Under normal circumstances,
these phenomena should be manageable and are not enough to explain the
horrendous amount of dying going on in bees.
Over recent years,
new insecticides have been introduced at the darn deadly to bs neonicotinoids.
A chemical family similar to nicotine was approved in the early 1990s as an
alternative to chemicals like Ddt.
They attack in sex by harming their nervous systems.
Today they are the most widely used insecticides in the world.
Globally.
They saw sales of 1.5 billion euros in 2008 representing 24% of the Global
Market for insecticides in 2013 neonicotinoids were used in the u s about 95% of
corn and canola crops and also on the vast majority of fruit and vegetable
like apples,
cherries,
peaches,
oranges.
There is leafy greens,
tomatoes,
potatoes,
cereal,
grains,
rice,
knucks,
grapes,
and many more.
These come into contact with the toxin while collecting pollen all via
contaminated water,
often bringing material into the hive where it can accumulate and slowly kill
the whole colony.
The toxins harm bees in a variety of horrible ways.
In high enough doses,
it quickly leads to convulsions,
paralysis and death,
but even in small doses,
it can be fatal.
It mainly to B's forgetting how to navigate the world,
so bees fly into the wild,
get lost and die alone,
separated from their hives.
If this happens often enough,
a hive can lose its ability to sustain itself.
We know that near nicotine IEDs are harmful to bees and that we urgently need an
alternative to it,
but there are billions of dollars to be made in delaying.
This study is sponsored by the chemical industry magically appear to prove a
much lower toxicity to bs compared to those produced by independent scientists.
There are even more factors contributing to the demise of B's like too much
genetic uniformity,
crop monocultures,
poor nutrition due to overcrowding stress because of human activities and other
pesticides.
Each of those factors on its own is a major problem for bees,
but together they probably account for colony collapse disorder with a parasites
upping their game.
In recent decades,
the honeybees are now fighting for survival.
It would be a catastrophe if they lost this fight.
This is a conundrum we have to solve if we want to continue living with a
relative abundance and diversity of food.
Humanity is deeply interconnected with earth and the other life forms on it.
Even if we pretend that we're not,
we have to take better care of our surroundings if not to preserve the beauty of
nature than at least to ensure our own survival.
This video is supported by the Australian Academy of Science,
which promotes and supports excellence in science.
See more as nova.org dot a u.
It was a blast to work with them,
so go check out their site.
Our videos are also made possible by your support on patrion.com recently we
passed an important milestone,
which is wind will be an additional video in July if you want to support us and
become part of the cuts because out bird army,
check out our patrion page.
Recently,
the Youtube Channel Field Day gave us the opportunity to make something
different.
A short video about game of Thrones.
Go check it out in their channel.